hey guys it's justine and guess what we
have here if you guessed airpods
generation three you would be correct i
am so excited about these because i
absolutely love the shape of the airpods
pro but i loved the fit of the original
airpods so the original design of the
airpods was actually taken from the
wired earbuds which i'm sure many of you
guys might remember but this is kind of
big news because apple actually did
change the design slightly for the new
ones so let's unbox them and check them
out um can we get a drum roll please
[Applause]
okay we still have one more thing
oh wow oh this is interesting i thought
this was going to be the exact same size
as the air pods pro case
and it looks like it's a little smaller
oh it is look at this
so this is the new gen 3 and this is the
air pods pro
from the top it kind of looks very
similar
[Music]
anything else oh yes we have a cable
thank you
and it's usbc
nice still lightning but the other end
is usbc
[Music]
let's take a look at these new air pods
it's so
much
smaller like look at that little stem
it's just
about the same size i think as the air
pods pro so let's line them up and just
really take a peek so gen 3
airpod pro and the previous
old-school airpod look at that that's a
long stick the real test though is
what's it going to fit like got a little
left and a little right and in
oh
they feel a little bit bigger
than the old versions which for my
little ears
okay i thought it was going to be a
problem
but the only thing that happened is i
got dizzy from shaking my head too much
they do have a little bit more of a
larger fit and feel it's actually a lot
larger interesting so here's what they
look like
okay here's the smile test i'm smiling
and they're not falling out this is all
really good news
one of the things that i love so much
about the airpods and homepods and
basically everything that apple has you
just have to bring it near your phone
and it's like hey do you want to set up
this thing yeah i do how did you know
and the new airpods are no exception
media control press once on either
airpod to play twice to skip forward
three times to see it backwards look at
this little tutorial yeah we'll do some
announcing oh it looks like my case
needs charged
so i guess i'll charge the case the one
thing that is great about these is the
increased battery life but how do they
sound all right
they are in my years they have connected
hits in spatial audio okay we definitely
need to listen in spatial audio
let's listen to a little ed sheeran
oh god it scared me
oh
[Music]
okay spatial freaking audio it's working
no way okay all right let me turn this
down this sound quality i'm freaking
blown away
the like especially with the spatial
audio like there's absolutely no
comparison to the previous version like
that this is
unbelievable i wish you guys could hear
this right now this is not me being
like over dramatic ijustine like this is
actually genuinely freaking awesome i am
so shook like the sound of the airpods
pro
is so good this is definitely on par
with it you just aren't gonna be getting
the noise cancellation features or the
transparency but this sounds amazing so
i think the real test is i'm gonna
actually have to use these like i can't
just be like cool i'm here at my desk i
listen to one single song i need to
actually take these somewhere i need to
go out i need to run i need to do my
daily activities i need to edit on these
and really see what they're like and
maybe i'll even take these on a little
trip test them out on an airplane
specifically just
for this video like i'm gonna hop on a
flight just because i need to test these
i really it's not like i had a trip
planned anyway i had to die i promise i
swear
[Music]
so the new air pods are actually pretty
awesome i have a weirdly shaped ear that
a lot of headphones do not work
especially earbuds so they did change
the shape they are slightly larger so
they don't fit as well for me but the
sound quality of these is so
just absolutely mind-blowing with a
spatial audio that i really can't get
over it i've been editing with them on
the new macbook i've been using it to go
for some runs i did actually travel this
past weekend i did a quick day trip to
napa and it was so awesome being able to
actually listen to these and use them on
the flight so i did get to test these
out in all of the scenarios that i
normally would be using my airpods and
they worked great they still fit i do
like that the stems are shorter i love
that these do have the force touch so
i'm able to control the audio if you
guys have never experienced the spatial
audio because they are only in the pro
version it's gonna blow your mind
i can't wait for you guys to experience
it i also posted my macbook review with
the new 16-inch macbook so if you guys
want to check that out i will put an end
card here link so you can check that out
i'll also put a link in the description
and if you guys haven't already be sure
to subscribe like this video hit the
bell so you'll be notified when i post
new videos and i'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]